Now that you know how to implement methods, let's move on to constructors. You
want to be able to create variations of objects. For example, a car that's very
fuel efficient or a car that is less so. In Java you use constructors to
initialize objects, here is an example. In the body of the constructor we
simply initialize the instance variables. The first two here are set to a
constant value. When a car is first created, it has not driven any miles and
its tank is empty. This instance variable is set to a parameter, and that
allows you to construct cars with different properties. Here, we construct a
car with 60 miles per gallon. The value 60 is passed into the parameter
variable. And is then set the instance variable here. Over here we construct a
car with 5 miles per gallon and again, the 5 is passed into the parameter
variable. And then used to initialize this instance variable. A couple of
things to pay attention to, when you define the constructor, note the name.
It's the same as the class name. The class is called car, the constructor is
called car. Also note that there's no return type at all not even void. The
constructor is not a method. It does not return any value. Instead the job of
constructor is just to initialize the instance variables. You can have more
than one constructor and you'll get a change to write one right now. Here is
our constructor in BlueJ, you see the statements that we had just before,
together with a couple of statements that set's the car's picture. Now this
constructure always takes the same picture to construct the car. It would be
much nicer if we could choose a different picture for every car, so let's do
that. I'd like you to write another constructure that takes two arguments, the
fuel efficiency and the picture file to be used. Go ahead and do that in the
coding environment and submit your answer.